huge news out of the world of horse
racing medina spirit the horse that won
the kentucky derby
failed a post-race drug test and might
be stripped of his victory did you hear
about this andy i did
big story doping yes yeah medina spirit
tested positive for an anti-inflammatory
steroid
which the owners deny ever giving to the
horse
in fact the horse's trainer bob baffert
has blamed the controversy on cancel
culture
that's right he's blaming cancel culture
uh we thought we have to get to the
bottom of this so uh we decided to talk
to the horse's trainer
himself horse racing legend
bob baffert uh hey there bob how you
doing
not too well conan i was wronged i feel
aggrieved it's a real
gut punch we did not give this drug to
our horse
all right we'll explain how did the drug
get into the horse's system
okay when my horses come home at 3 a.m i
don't ask them where they've been
or what they put in their system that's
their business
okay well rules are rules and steroids
are illegal bob
everything's illegal with the woke mob i
mean i had to change
the names of three of my horses sweet
tits sir farts a lot
carpet munch you believe that uh no i
think they should have changed those
names that was a good call
so they've gotten to you see now they're
saying i gotta put my old horses out to
pasture instead of feeding them to my
greyhounds you feed horses to greyhounds
that seems
it's insane well listen it's cancel this
it's cancel that next thing you know
jockeys will want to be recognized as
humans jockeys are humans
you don't keep a human in a cage and
feed him pine cones
wait is that what you do pine cones are
in season yes
look that's insane bob whatever or
whoever you think is to blame for this
this is a violation so i think you have
to answer to that oh
it's a gut punch it's a real gut punch
every day now they're telling me i have
to race
girl horses too even though they rarely
win and they're not as funny as male
horses it's not fair
what are you what are you talking about
listen you can't even make a living
anymore conan this gen z
cancel culture woke mob i mean they're
costing me a fortune in my other
businesses too [ __ ] fighting
dog fighting bomb fighting [ __ ] on bomb
fights
dog on [ __ ] fights bomb on horse versus
dog on jockey fights
okay you know what i we get it all right
still explain the steroids
woke mob woke mob conan okay explain
this
artificial glue from chemicals is good
but natural glue made from horses
is bad okay peter what next are you
going to come after me for sending dick
pics to the horses come on you know what
we're out of time we're out of time
don't
don't send dick pics to horses that's
for stupid bob baffert everybody
it makes no sense to send a dick pic to
a horse
all right we got a great show
shawn hayes is here what does it have to
do with a woke mob you don't send a dick
pic to a horse
some of them sent pics back to me all
right okay that's different
that's the horse's choice not yours sean
hayes he'll be right here in just a
second
you feed pinecones to jockeys who
doesn't
all right well i gotta look into this